everybody welcome to the first hashtag
askgaryvee I think it's the first one
but I actually do think I tried to do
this once before I feel like I've got
the team now in place to actually do
this more often so here we go
you know the long tail just moving the
goalposts is an interesting kind of
question you're asking a very
interesting question of a very specific
character meaning I am so long term I'm
so by the Jets that the stuff in between
is less important every decision I make
from vaynermedia to deciding to write
books to speaking to doing this right
now is predicated on how does that chess
move to me actually owning the Jets one
day I'll tell you what what I think
about this I understand the thesis and
the question and I though tone is often
lost on Twitter I think I know where
you're going which is a cool you can
have a big picture but if you're not
executing properly in the short term do
you actually get there to me it's
actually the reverse I find that one of
the biggest reasons I've able to build
big businesses make smart investments
I'm now on my second business that I've
operated from a small base to a huge
base in one second is because when you
have a big picture in mind a North Star
the long-term vision something
interesting happens and I'm going to get
close here Joe you stop you stop
stressing the dumb little shits day in
and day out because you're playing the
big game and so what happens is the
short term angst which is really the
friction of growth actually becomes a
little bit more manageable a little
easier to deal with and I have found by
having those big visions I'm moving the
short goalposts moves quicker faster
more importantly and so you know I'm one
of these pro go all-in deep big
long-term vision calculate towards it at
all times and you'll find that being 85%
effective in your short term moves
because you're 110% effective and
focused on your long-term goal is
actually moving you quicker along the
way
did you talk I feel like the first fax
owner every day of my life can you
imagine how I feel I'm usually really at
the forefront of these things and so um
you know I'm gonna give you a very
simple piece of advice I try not to
convert anyone from all the pieces of
content I'm all the t-shirts we make
show Zach they'll like that he made the
t-shirt from all the things I do the
quote cards the the keynotes the books
the ranting and raving these videos
truth is I don't give a crap about
converting one person I'm only speaking
to the converted and so if your market
hasn't moved yet and they don't believe
in fax machines be and you're trying to
sell a fax machine don't try to convince
somebody to buy a fax machine go find
the people that already have bought into
the fax machine and just sell it to them
because if you're too early in a theory
or a business where nobody has bought in
you've lost so for everybody who thinks
I'm Nostradamus or I'm far ahead the
truth is I'm not far ahead I'm just
practical and realized there's enough
scale in the reality of 2014 right now
marketing there's enough people buying
in to make it practical and there was
even enough in 2009 when I started
vaynermedia with AJ when nobody thought
I was ready or the market was ready or
anybody was ready there was just enough
for us to actually build a business and
then we grew into it we skated to where
the puck was going to be as that classic
statement is and so you know that's my
answer you know don't try to convert
anybody don't waste energy on people
that can't consume it just go on the
full offense and the people that have
already bought it
as building off audiences on Pinterest
and YouTube with Facebook dark posts is
the wrong strategy in a world where you
can build YouTube audience with
pre-rolls
at five to seven cents a view and
Pinterest is about 20 seconds away from
their ad platform so my answer to you is
it's nice to try to siphon I do fit
thing Facebook dark posts will probably
be the most effective
besides the native way to do it but if
you're trying to build YouTube and
Pinterest audience I highly recommend
doing it with the native app platforms
within those two principle parties
sétimo when I buy the New York Jets I
will become the kind of owner that makes
Mark Cuban and Jerry Jones seem passive
not only will I probably touch personnel
decisions there's a dark-horse chance
that you'll hear and starting at wide
receiver number five Gary Vaynerchuk I
will reshape the mold of ownership in
American sports history
drag them you know honestly I don't know
why Steve show them I don't know why
Steve picked this question because the
truth is there's not enough context how
do we apply it to your music world I
don't know what do you do do you like
put on shows it's easy do you sell
t-shirts or vans easy do you try to
resell music a little tricky I mean I'll
need a little more context I'm going to
allow you to retweet with more context
and we'll get you back on the show
keV first of all I'm so ridiculously
jealous that you're 21 it makes me want
to vomit on myself I always say that I'd
give up everything to be 21 and I mean
it the knowledge would be tough to give
up but I think I mean it time is the
asset you know look I uh I wrote a piece
about what I would do if I was a real
estate agent on LinkedIn about Twitter
being a links searching on Twitter is
gold and then just putting out content
there's some guy early on in 2009 when I
wrote crush it who completely jumped on
it and crushed it at as a real estate
agent putting like a flip cam on his car
while he drove but the truth is it's
putting out content and it's using
Twitter as an offense and joy
seven you're not selling a heart product
and I paid attention to how you frame
worked your question but the truth is
ultimately Aven I think you're trying to
play chess to get a donation I will tell
you that the number one sector in social
media that is most struggled in my
opinion is nonprofit an NGO the amount
of people because I have over a million
followers on Twitter that hit me up
every day every day 15 people a day on
Twitter that hit me up for can you give
to charity can you retweet this for our
charity without even saying hello can
you romance a girl I mean it makes no
sense and so the way you do it the way
you sell that culture is look there's
charity water as the gold standard my
opinion of heavy storytelling through
content I would look at that as a model
it's about putting out good content it's
about engaging with people around their
issues that's searching the terms much
like the last question around whatever
you're trying to solve and jumping into
conversations
it's about effort instead of you know
there's an entitlement on the nonprofit
NGO space that needs to be broken for
them to be successful in an open
transparent one-on-one world where it's
not guilting or relying on what people
think they have to give I dinner last
night with the CEO of a major NGO
nonprofit and I said I feel great giving
back and he said no stop get rid of the
word back it's just good giving by
saying giving back it's like you've
taken something and it really was
powerful and so I think we need to get
to a place where it's not what's
expected it's what's appreciated and
that can be completely executed on
social better than any other place
because it's transparent it's open get
into conversations show the effort
romance a girl execute my friends I'm
excited about this as you can see
there's very attractive people
associated with this organization I
think we're going to be doing it more
often especially because the man behind
the mic d-roc is now here and I feel
like we've got this I will be tweeting
out more questions use the hashtag
anytime you want you know and I'll see
you later